Trascrizione: Martina Margoni
Revisore: Federico Sangati
Ciao Trento!
Abbiamo un problema.
Ve lo dico subito...
che è quello che io sento dire
da tanti studenti e da tanti colleghi
Non si può più fare impresa.
Perchè? Perché le tecnologie
sostituiscono il lavoro
e le banche
non ti danno il capitale.
Tra i tanti mestieri che faccio,
c'è anche quello del venture capitalist.
e quindi un po' di capitale
di solito ce lo metto io.
Ma prima di metterci il mio capitale,
chiedo ai futuri imprenditori:
"Ma perché il capitale ed il lavoro
non lo prendi dai tuoi clienti"?
Stasera parliamo di "hiring
costumers", assumere i clienti.
I clienti che, i miei colleghi
del dipartimento di marketing,
vogliono sempre celebrare dicendo:
"Metteteli al centro dei vostri progetti!"
Macché al centro! Mettiamoli sotto,
facciamo lavorare questi clienti.
E' questo il senso.
E guarda che non era solo un'idea mia.
Vi faccio capire che 150 anni fa
qualcuno ci aveva già pensato.
E non sorprendetevi se
un bocconiano cita Carlo Marx.
(risate)
Cosa diceva Carlo Marx?
Onestamente anche
un sacco di stupidaggini,
però due cose le ha azzeccate.
La prima era una cosa
molto semplice;
diceva che i mezzi di produzione
devono appartenere al popolo.
Se vi frugate in tasca
ciascuno di noi ha almeno
uno dei più grandi mezzi
di produzione della storia.
Produzione dell'informazione,
produzione dei mezzi di pagamento.
Abbiamo visto prima le blockchain.
Immaginate di avere in tasca
uno dei più grandi mezzi
di produzione al mondo.
Quando il capitalismo
perde il controllo sui mezzi di produzione,
perché finiscono al popolo,
diventa un problema usare il capitale.
La seconda cosa che diceva Marx era:
"Lavoratori di tutto il mondo unitevi".
Lui aveva in mente
il partito comunista.
Io molto più semplicemente,
ho in mente Twitter, Linkedin
che sono meccanismi
di coordinamento del popolo.
E pensate che un personaggio
come Mark Zuckerberg,
dal mio punto di vista,
è un imprenditore marxista.
Perché che cos'è Facebook se non
la più grande azienda di media al mondo,
senza aver mai assunto un giornalista,
senza aver mai comprato un'edicola.
Che cos'è d'altra parte WhatsApp,
se non la più grande azienda
di telecomunicazioni al mondo
senza una torre o un call center.
Che cos'è Uber se non
la più grande azienda di logistica
senza automobili e senza dipendenti.
Cos'è Airbnb?
Che usa il vostro capitale,
la vostra casa e il vostro lavoro
per diventare la più grande
azienda di ospitalità al mondo.
Quindi quattro aziende
che potrei dire "marxiste",
nel senso che hanno utilizzato
l'intelligenza distribuita,
per fare a meno del capitale
e a meno del lavoro.
Questo è un principio
che sta prendendo piede
e che quindi toglie
la grande scusa del:
"Ah, non troviamo il capitale
dai fornitori tradizionali, le banche
e non abbiamo più il lavoro
perché le macchine lo sostituiscono".
Quindi il principio è molto semplice:
provate ad assumere
il vostro cliente!
Hire your costumer!
Questo è il messaggio
della serata.
Niente di nuovo
se ci pensate.
Non so chi di voi ha mai visto
quella chiave a brugola.
(Risate)
Strumento di masochismo
meccanico;
una delle esperienze
più allucinanti della nostra vita.
Nei week end, ogni tanto mia moglie
dice: "Perché non andiamo all'Ikea"?
Io: "No!" E le spiego
che microeconomicamente
è un esperimento marxista.
Perchè? Perché schiavizza i clienti.
E' andata così, eh!
Con semplici istruzioni, peraltro
avete notato che Ikea non ha testi?
Perché giustamenente non avendo
tempo e voglia di tradurli,
ci ha sostanzialmente illustrato
il meccanismo di lavoro volontario,
noi paghiamo per lavorare,
pensate un po'!
E il disegno fondamentale
del prodotto è incompleto
senza il contributo, il capitale
e il lavoro dei clienti.
Il capitale è che ci metti la macchina
e il portapacchi e anche i soldi
poi vai a casa e passi il weekend
a montare la libreria Billy.
Questo è il principio per cui Ikea
è antesignana dei vari Facebook e Linkedin
ma è di fatto un modello
molto intelligente.
Visto che sto citando filosofi marxisti
non poteva mancare Antonio Gramsci,
il quale, grande uomo,
grande intellettuale,
scrisse dal carcere, perché
all'epoca c'erano i fascisti
...all'epoca! Oggi figuriamoci...
e mettevano in galera gli intellettuali.
e Gramsci scrisse
questa bella biografia
che era sostanzialmente
"l'intellettuale organico".
E disse: "Io odio gli indifferenti,
odio chi non parteggia".
Lo credo, eh
lo avevano lasciato
rinchiuso in carcere!
Perché Gramsci ha ragione?
E ci dice ancora oggi, che il cliente
deve essere come il suo intellettuale:
"organico", che non vuol dire
che è senza pesticidi,
ma che lo "coltiviamo"
dentro la nostra organizzazione.
Questo è il concetto di organico.
E se ci pensate questo è il senso
di un'azienda come Tripadvisor.
Tripadvisor, che cosa è?
La nemesi della guida Michelin.
Una volta dovevamo assumere
degli esperti indipendenti
che dovevano andare
in tutti i vari settori
della ristorazione e dell'ospitalità
e dare dei giudizi oggettivi.
Oggi ciascuno di noi partecipa,
in questo senso
Tripadvisor odia gli indifferenti,
partecipa alla produzione
di questa consapevolezza collettiva.
Ciascuno di noi è membro
di un'organizzazione distribuita
che produce un capitale sociale
fondamentale
un bene pubblico fondamentale,
che è la fiducia, il "trust".
D'altra parte noi tutti, oggi,
su questo modello produttivo
ci mettiamo le mani...
Anzi le mani, le mettiamo all'Ikea.
Su Tripadvisor,
noi mettiamo le dita.
Ma lo facciamo anche su Facebook:
mettiamo il pollice se siamo felici, "I like".
Su Linkdin mettiamo l'indice
addirittura facciamo le connessioni.
Su Tripadvisor, a volte capita
che mettiamo il pollice? No.
L'indice? No, forse il medio...
perché esprimiamo dissenso.
Guardate che il dissenso
è elemento fondamentale.
Pensate che oggi per fondare un partito
minimo minimo vi servono 5 stelle.
E a volte serve il pollice,
l'indice e, in certi casi, il medio!
La verità è che le aziende
cercano l'anulare,
cioè cercano il contratto
di fedeltà e fiducia.
Questa è la sfida fondamentale,
perché alla fine è sempre il cliente
che ci mette il capitale ed il lavoro.
D'altra parte oggi, voi tutti,
anche solo per andare in pizzeria
ormai consultate
non più la guida Michelin
ma quel prodotto di capitale esperienziale
collettivo e di lavoro collettivo
che è appunto Tripadvisor.
Fare impresa oggi è difficile
se pensate che anche
un kebabbaro albanese
se vuole aprire un kebab a Trento
come minimo deve avere
quattro palle verdi.
Una volta ne bastavano un paio di palle,
adesso minimo quattro
o cinque, se volete
proprio avere successo.
Questo però presuppone che anche
il modello organizzativo di impresa cambi.
Ed il premio Nobel,
di qualche giorno fa, all'economia
che è Richard Thaler,
professore a Chicago,
ha vinto il premio Nobel perché ha capito
che non sono più le gerarchie
e i modelli organizzativi antichi
ma sono le spinte gentili,
sono sistemi di incentivi che convincono,
in maniera intelligente e morbida,
i clienti, a fare
quello che volete voi!
Quindi, la teoria cosa dice?
Mi raccomando, dagli una leggera spinta,
non spingere, non spingere.
Devi creare un sistema
di incentivi corretti
e a questo punto, il cliente partecipa
al tuo gioco organizzativo.
Perché? Perché gli stai dando
accesso alle informazioni
internet questo ha fatto,
ma gli stai dando anche
gli strumenti di partecipare
alla tua sfida organizzativa.
E questo è quello che succede:
Il libretto di lavoro e la tessera
del sindacato collassano
nel nostro telefonino, nel mezzo
di produzione che appartiene al popolo.
Pensate a questi due fenomeni:
una tessera sindacale
e cioè il contratto che difende
gli interessi del popolo, del lavoratore,
ormai è diventata
un meccanismo collettivo.
È il social rating che ci difende,
molto più delle tradizionali
associazioni di consumatori.
Noi siamo in grado, come clienti,
di svergognare un'azienda sui social
molto prima che intervenga
l'antitrust o il tribunale
per condannarla.
Oggi peraltro noi stipuliamo un contratto
di lavoro di collaborazione.
Per esempio, con Google Maps,
noi tutti forniamo
al posto del cantoniere tradizionale
o della polizia stradale,
informazioni sul traffico
puntuali, precise, volontarie
e che producono un bene pubblico.
Questo è importante perché ha cambiato
la scala di Maslow di questi ultimi tempi.
Vi ricordate la scala di Maslow?
In alto ha i bisogni di appartenenza
poi al centro, ha i bisogni organizzativi
e in basso, ha i bisogni di base:
nutrimento, cibo, caldo, freddo,
non dico l'altra cosa, ma ci siamo intesi.
I miei studenti non sono più così:
posso chiuderli 48 ore in aula
senza cibo, senza acqua
e non fanno troppo casino.
Ma se tolgo il wifi e la batteria
questi mi fanno scoppiare la rivoluzione!
Ed è quello che succede oggi
in questo modello qua.
Ormai siamo tenuti a partecipare
a questi processi sociali.
D'altra parte, ormai, oltre al lavoro
il cliente deve portare il capitale.
Non lo devono più dare le banche.
Prima, il collega ha detto che il Cloud
non esiste, è solo il computer degli altri.
E' vero! La banca non esiste
è solo il capitale degli altri.
Che cosa ci dicono
questi due "moderni" filosofi?
Uno ha 150 anni
ed è Pierre-Joseph Proudhon
e l'altro è un moderno filosofo,
leggermente figlio di buona donna,
è Travis Kalanick,
il fondatore Uber.
Proudhon diceva 150 anni fa
che "la proprietà è un furto".
Io più modestamente
do ragione a Kalanick che dice:
"La proprietà non è un furto,
ma un metodo molto inefficiente
di allocare gli asset
e le risorse produttive".
E devo dire che ha ragione Kalanick
il quale sostanzialmente si è inventato
un metodo per allocare le risorse
produttive distribuite sul territorio,
convincendo in maninera gentile,
con il "nudging" di cui parlava Thaler
o, alle volte, anche
in maniera meno gentile.
Certamente, lo ha fatto Airbnb:
chi di voi cinque anni fa
avrebbe preso un aereo
e sarebbe partito per il Wyoming
per andare in una fattoria sperduta
in mezzo ai bufali e tra sconosciuti?
Nessuno eh? Peccato che
con l'arrivo di Airbnb,
voi tutti fate esattamente questo,
perché il capitale ed il lavoro
sono stati forniti da questa rete sociale.
Quindi il passaggio, sul capitale,
è proprio questo:
quello che ci dice che
il nuovo capitale sono i dati.
Pensate a questa grande forma
di socialismo digitale
che scatterà l'anno prossimo.
Questo è Lenin, che ci indica
quello che succederà.
L'anno prossimo, l'Unione Europea
farà due cose straordinarie
su cui vi invito a riflettere.
La prima si chiama GDPR
e la seconda si chiama PSD2.
Sono due direttive,
che fanno che cosa?
Espropriano le aziende, le banche
e le istituzioni della proprietà del dato
e restituiscono la proprietà
del dato a ciascuno di noi.
Quindi, non c'è più nessuna scusa
per non fare impresa.
perché dall'anno prossimo,
l'Unione Europea,
che ha tanti difetti
ma a volte ci azzecca,
espropria i titolari della proprietà
del dato, del loro diritto di proprietà
lascia loro il possesso, la custodia,
ma affida a chi abbia la capacità
di convincere il cliente
di affidargli quel compito,
il potere di ottenere quel dato
e sfidare le grandi organizzazioni.
Quindi è una grandissima opportunità
quella del 2018, una grande rivoluzione;
è la finestra di un socialismo digitale
molto interessante, anche per un liberale.
Chiudo dicendo: il principio del fare
impresa cambia profondamente.
Siamo cresciuti, e noi stessi l'abbiamo
insegnato ai nostri studenti,
un modello di impresa
molto calligrafico,
un po' come Piero della Francesca
che introdusse la prospettiva.
Lui faceva il matematico ma,
siccome non guadagnava abbastanza,
si mise a dipingere.
Dipingendo, interpretò
il senso della matematica,
cioè rigore e formalismo.
E' un po' come i nostri business plan:
tutto pianificato, rigoroso,
prospettiva centrale, tutti
che guardano nella stessa direzione.
Ma quel mondo ordinato e preciso
rischia di finire.
In effetti, qualche centinaia d'anni dopo
è arrivato quel genio di Pablo Picasso
quindi se Piero ha messo ordine, Pablo
ha messo un grande disordine organizzato.
Pablo Picasso aveva tecnica sopraffina.
Lui diceva: "Ci ho messo vent'anni
per imparare a disegnare come Raffaello,
ci metterò il resto della vita per
imparare a disegnare come un bambino".
La sua capacità di semplificare
è di introdurre, nella logica del cubismo,
la legittimazione
di diverse prospettive.
Lui è l'inventore del cubismo.
Oggi, l'economia dei dati
è un grande iper-cubo,
una grande e legittima
prospettiva diversa.
Questo è, secondo me, il suo quadro
più famoso, Les Demoiselles d'Avignon
che sta al MOMA di New York.
Le signorine d'Avignone.
Non mi fate dire il contesto
in cui questo quadro è stato dipinto,
perché penso che sia intuitivo.
Ma che cos'è questo quadro?
Questo quadro è la legittimazione
strutturale della diversa prospettiva,
questo quadro, come il cubismo,
legittima le prospettive
di lato, sopra, sotto,
tutte sono accettate, tutte sono
scomposte e sintetizzate.
E' il concetto che stiamo utilizzando;
il capitale estetico
e il lavoro percettivo del cliente.
Pablo Picasso ce l'aveva indicata
la via, cento anni fa:
attribuire la legittimazione organizzativa
estetica, agli occhi del cliente.
Quindi chiudo dicendo questo:
e torno in Italia,
con la più bella scultura
che può rappresentare
la chiusura di questo TEDx
e la mission che vi lascio,
e cioè quella di diventare un ibrido,
di diventare una contaminazione,
di diventare un po' cyborg,
un filino bastardi,
inteso come sintesi
di uomo e macchina.
Questa scultura, bellissima,
di Umberto Boccioni
sta al Museo del Novecento a Milano
ed è la perfetta rappresentazione
di questo equilibrio
del nostro tempo.
Una sintesi di vuoti e di pieni,
di uomo e di macchina,
di chiari e di scuri,
è un disegno e un progetto bellissimo.
E' un progetto che, come dicevo prima,
non richiede poi così tanti capitali
perché alla fine bastano 20 centesimi
per ricordarsi di questa bella storia.
Io non so quindi se siete
leoni o gazzelle,
ma vi chiedo
di cominciare a correre!
Grazie TEDx!
Grazie!
(Applausi)